fonelle politique avec nos trois
panélistes ce soir hélène buzzetti pas
le jour n'est pas loin bonsoir à vous
tous bonsoir bonsoir bon l'invasion
d'ukraine évidemment tout le monde là
déplore et tout le monde s'en désole on
sent vraiment que quelque chose de très
affectif aussi là dedans mais quand on
regarde les faits sur la popularité des
dirigeants de regarder au canada les
faits sur la popularité de justin
trudeau mais il ya un sondage de la
firme mérou kasic finalement que ça joue
plutôt en faveur de monsieur de monsieur
trudeau le 65 % des gens qui le
soutiennent dans sa gestion 58% c'est sa
réponse à la crise 53% le voient comme
un bon leader et là une réaction là
dessus
c'est très passager ce genre de sondage
là c'est certainement réjouissant pour
un leader ça ne veut pas dire que ça va
être durable mais sans vouloir être
cynique c'est très fréquente des crises
comme ça ait pour effet de rameuter
l'opinion publique derrière le leader
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'à long terme
le on va tout lui pardonner mais pour
l'instant monsieur trudeau ça lui permet
quand même de faire oublier un certain
nombre de choses en premier lieu cette
loi sur les mesures d'urgence qui avait
été adoptée puis abandonné le pour mater
la question des camionneurs et puis on
en parle plus du tout il ya eu débat la
chambre des communes aujourd'hui là mais
néanmoins alors ça permet comme ceux
d'évacuer les cils et les sujets
désagréable mais à long terme ça peut
revenir il prévoit aussi des effets
néfastes aussi de cette crise pour
monsieur trudeau parce que sa gestion de
la crise des camionneurs justement de
ces grands blocage aussi aux frontières
paul wells c'était perçu très
différemment par la population
oui mais sur la question essentielle
lors du convoi des soi-disant
camionneurs mais surtout ils ont été
très largement du côté de l'opinion
publique
la vaccination le continent ça a été
très soutenu et est donc ce serait
intéressant de voir si après le convoi
déçoit d un camionneur après les faits
des ralliements d'une crème de voir si
ça ne fait sur les intentions de vote
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose que
de voir ce que les gens
appuient de façon générale la position
du canada que qui est identique aux
positions de tous les gouvernements du
monde la question est de savoir est-ce
qu'il ya plus de monde qui voit qu'ils
vont voter libéral et là je suis pas
certain
j'ai l'impression que le vote libéral
plafonne depuis déjà trois 3 ans et
c'est pas une guerre en europe c'est
même pas en guerre en quarts en europe
qui va changer ça du jour au lendemain
il reste que sur le plan de la
perception par le journée le type de
leadership est très différent ça piétine
et vraiment pendant la crise de
camionneurs on avait l'impression d'une
espèce d'inertie avec les paliers de
gouvernement qui disent c'est pas dans
ma cour sa percée à la ville d'ottawa
par exemple alors que la gouvernement
est très présent aux états d'âme fui
l'inde est très présente aussi lead
beaucoup le savent cette crise avec
l'ukraine d'avoir une vice première
ministre qui parle la langue celle d'une
nuit popstar en terrain de plus crise il
mais je pense que ce qui profite surtout
aux gouvernements de philo c'est le fait
que leclerc s'est défait de ralliement
dans une crise mais surtout j'ai peu de
contraste marqué entre ce que les
libéraux font est ce que les oppositions
propose notamment parce que les recours
du canada dans un tel conflit sont assez
limitées si vous regardez les débats il
ya pas de grandes fractures idéologiques
quant aux interventions qu'elle canada
devrait faire donc en censeur si le seul
sujet qui occupe ou presque l'actualité
c'est l'agression russe en ukraine et
que ce que le gouvernement trudeau fait
ça ressemble un petit peu près ce que
les oppositions voudrait c'est normal
qu'ils aient un appui à monsieur trudeau
se le dit dans les sondages et de choses
qu'on peut regarder les grandes
tendances de fond et les fluctuations
les facturations mon simple attirer
notre attention on peut faire de grandes
analyses mais c'est des vagues passagère
et je sais pas quelle sera la prochaine
campagne électorale
c'est pourquoi le conflit mais je doute
qu'on soit dans les tendances de fond
avec soul c'est plutôt
6 à 8 heures un épiphénomène point de
vue la politique canadienne est ce que
la crise on écrit on a presque éclipsé
la pandémie dont on parlait tout au tout
les jours pendant des années mais on va
en parler encore ce soir a conçu cette
information curieuse déterré par notre
collègue thomas gerber on se rappelle
tout ce dernier couvre feu qui avait été
imposé la fin décembre thomas jobin
finalement nous apprend que six heures
avant le point de presse nous condamnons
c'est la position du couvre-feu monsieur
avoue doc est encore directeur de la
santé publique chercher des études
chercher une justification scientifique
pour être capable de répondre aux
questions des journalistes lors de l'
annonce et il n'en a pas trouvé il a
fait appel aux experts aliens sp qu il
n'en a pas trouvé hélène qu'est-ce que
sa vie dit finalement sur cette idée
d'imposer un couvre-feu parce que le
gouvernement se défend des en faisant
non non non on le fait qu' on est
toujours guidé par la santé publique
mais d'abord on s'en doute est bien là
qui en avait pas de justification ou de
d'assises scientifique sinon on nous
l'aurait offerte il ya longtemps de ça
mais ça peut être sa vie confirmé une
impression que l'on avait à propos de
monsieur à roue d'or et qui explique en
partie son départ se fait qu' il jouait
beaucoup un rôle politique et dans le
cas qui nous occupe celui de ce deuxième
couvre feu c'est la politique qui a
commandé ce couvre feu et on a ensuite
cherché une justification scientifique
sur laquelle l'appuyer ce couvre-feu et
c'était pas nécessairement sur le rôle
de monsieur arruda donc ça vient
vraiment confirmé une impression que
l'on avait des mesures ou haruna qui se
retrouvaient un peu trop peut-être dans
l'équipe politique mais ceci dit moi je
demeure convaincu que ce couvre-feu là
il a été proposé à la dernière minute
devant les chiffres affolants
d'hospitalisation et qui était surtout
pour éviter les partis deux jours de là
on a le parc il ya des défaites et on ne
trouvait que prend le couvre-feu était
la façon la plus rapide des de les
empêcher ces fêtes la part dans la
période habituelle de congés des
citoyens et c'est pour ce qu ont eu
recours je pense que ça a été comme ça
une phase un raccourci que l'on a pris
parce que c'était plus facile oui mais
on a bien vu les faits par exemple effet
sur la cac sap a passé auprès de la
population par journée je reviens vous
ici y'a pas au gouvernement qui est
content d'imposer un couvre-feu ici que
c'est pas très vendeur évidemment
pourquoi pas simplement dire la vérité
aux gens dire écouter les parties là on
ne peut pas le faire on prend pas de
couvre-feu on court pas après vous avec
des policiers on va vous expliquer tout
simplement observer la question de la
transparence sur ces sols
web et si on avait procédé comme ça je
pense que ça a été
façon c'est une question d'honnêteté que
c'est plutôt parce qu'on y va avec la
carotte ou le bâton entre autres la pâte
mais la recommandation de la commission
mais il faut quand même mieux revenir
dans le temps la piraterie q2 couvre-feu
le premier et sas avait été bien
documenté ce n'était pas une suggestion
du gouvernement le box avec les suggérée
par la santé publique plus précisément
par le docteur hérite litvak et le
gouvernement leveaux avait accepté à
reculons vous avez hésité pendant
environ une journée donc ce n'est pas
une décision politique dans un premier
temps entre autres parce qu'il y aura un
gouvernement qui va en profiter
politiquement
dans le 2ème couvre feu peut-être que
leurs yeux un raisonnement comme celui
dont parle hélène qu' on était débordé
on avait laissé le plus trop comment
convaincre les jardins but rassembler
chez eux et qu'on en a sorti ce pur
bonheur maintenant à la question de la
vie scientifique y avait déjà des études
qui sans établir un lien causal montrer
que ça pouvait faire partie des outils
nombre par mako logique que des
interventions plus sociale de politiques
publiques se juger par le chercheur il y
en a mais on n'est pas capable de
démontrer un lien causal
n'hypothèque même une corrélation forte
et nu mais la grande question je trouve
ces baies pourquoi est-ce qu'on refuse
de pourquoi est ce que le document de
votre collègue
qui le demandait a été caviardé si ya
pas de justification pour ça c'était la
belgique qui avait été demandé en vain
quatre à six heures vous donc pour
répondre aux questions de la santé
publique de montréal mme hélène drouin
qu'elle n'était pas en faveur de ce
couvre feu non puis rapidement on aurait
pu quand même trouver des justifications
scientifiques sa méthode d'autorité
programme de les trouver lui-même mais
ce genre de décision de caviar d'un
document et les prises par les gens dans
l'administration publique qui gère les
demandes d'accès à l'information pour
cabinet du bureau de premier ministre
mais à tout le moins nous sommes rentrés
mareuil ce genre de manque de
transparence
des jeunes épaules quand on compare
justement les mesures prises au québec
ce couvre-feu entre automne au plus haut
dans les autres provinces et là on est
entrée de d confiné au québec on est en
train d'avancer on en parlait avec des
routes express sont tous là on est en
train d'avancer un peu l'agenda l'on
prend de la vitesse un peu mais si on se
compare avec le reste du canada on va
montrer la carte on reste quand même à
prendre la colombie-britannique dans les
provinces où on maintient le plus
longtemps les mesures comme le masque et
le passeport vaccinale aussi donc c'est
quand même curieux de voir à quel point
les autres se sont plus rapidement
débarrassé de ses mesures sanitaires
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
oui ça ne veut pas forcément dire que
les autres raisons est que le québec a
tort chaque province
se sert des outils choisis en fonction
et de la science et des pressions
politiques et la culture locale et
chacun prend un pari j'ai été un peu
étonné de voir lors du discours du
président bart hayden d'un congrès hier
soir que quelques jours à peine après
qu'on ait rendu
non obligatoire la primaire il y avait
presque personne dans une salle bondée
de 400
personnes il avait presque personne qui
portait une masque
c'est un pari qu'on prend c'est certain
qu'il y aura plus d'écart plus de cas
c'est certain qu'il y aura pas autant
d'hospitalisation mais au moins légère
remontée et et chaque gouvernement
d'après ce soit en fonction de cela ce
qui est malsain et je suis d'accord avec
mes collègues c'est la soupe politique
aux scientifiques dans laquelle baigne à
tous les gouvernements depuis deux ans
jacques nous vraiment présente ses
experts scientifiques
qui travaillent à la solde du grand noir
comme bouclier c'est pas mon choix s'est
scellée science qui dicte
les difficiles démarche qu'on est obligé
à entreprendre alors que chacun sait ou
devrait savoir que la science ne donne
pas des solutions il donne des consignes
à des probabilités et en fonction de
savoir les gouvernements choisissent
voilà et c'est ça qu'on a qu'on courait
apprend avec cette histoire du dr
leur parlons maintenant de jean charest
parce que vous savez que ce soir les
vite les conservateurs à elle une
rencontre et il était à ottawa nous
dit-on dans le centre ville un lieu qui
n'a pas été rendu public mais les villes
invitation est lancée à tous il ya
quelques conservateurs qui ont accepté
de réagir au micro de nos collègues
ottawa on va les écouter
non là malheureusement j'ai un autre
réunion
oui pourquoi parce que cet excès de
candeur
on a déjà tout aussi à la chambre on va
regarder ce qu'on peut faire mais non
c'est un miroir
des majors
un tour dans le temps
bon bah je vais commencer avec vous pour
cette fois ci dites-moi est-ce que vous
pensez que les gens vont être nombreux à
les accepter l'invitation à rencontrer
monsieur charest ce soir est ce qu'ils
vont avoir beaucoup de questions à lui
poser il devrait l'être par simple
courtoisie mais pour plusieurs d'entre
d'entre eux ce ne sera que de la
courtoisie mais si je reconnais bien des
députés conservateurs sur tous les
québécois
il a gelé souvent vu dans des événements
quand stephen harper premier ministre du
québec gelé souvent vous à des soirées
avec le député conservateur de l'époque
mais il polarise le caucus comme le
parti
ceux qui sont plutôt de tendance à
progressistes-conservateurs
accueillir est plutôt bien sa
candidature et ceux qui sont plutôt
alliancistes voire 30 pistes
beaucoup moins et on a vu un peu sous la
dent dans les réponses de députés que
vous avez montré way and là dessus et
souvent des gens qui vont vérifier
jusqu'à quel point monsieur charest est
encore un conservateur quel genre de
conservateurs soit quand même 20 ans qui
met plus conservateur progressiste
conservateur surtout c'était un tout
autre parti mais dans les citations que
vous avez fait jouer tout à l'heure
quelqu'un a dit je n'ai pas encore
vérifié mon agenda et ça en fait j'ai
fait là aujourd'hui à cette entrée de
caucus on a posé la question à tout le
monde qu'ils passaient et cette réponse
était visiblement une ligne écrite
préparés d'avancé
plusieurs députés nous l'on fournisse je
poserai voile et ils veulent pas
dévoiler leur jeu exacte et ce en soit
je trouve ça quand même révélateur le
fait qu'on soit même jaïn et et de dire
qu'on va rencontrer un ancien chef de
notre parti politique de notre de lens à
être en tout cas de notre parti
politique ça démontre à quel point comme
le dit paul c'est quand même un
personnage dans le contexte de ce
nouveau parti conservateur qui est un
peu qui vend qui ne fait pas les
affaires de tout le monde et donc on est
un petit peu gêné de se présenter ceci
dit je mentionne que on vous parlait
tout à l'heure la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence qui doit faire l'objet de deux
comités ce soir il doit y avoir un vote
lors je vous épargne les détails très
procédurale mais il doit y avoir un vote
doremi donc ça va peut-être un peu
nourrir à la fête mais il faut aussi
garder à l'esprit que même s'il devait y
avoir beaucoup de monde ce soir les
députés ne représente quand même qu'un
seul vote chacun voilà pour la chefferie
alors vous pouvez avoir beaucoup de
députés derrière vous ça ne vous
garantit pas le succès d'ailleurs je
pense que monsieur mais qui la dernière
fois c'est lui qui avait le plus de
députés de son coup il n'y a pas dans la
rue mais ça aide quand même je vais avec
quinze journées à préparer
sont comment dire sa sortie publique le
dévoilé voilà je me présente j'ai des
appuis les voici il manteau aujourd'hui
belle surtout pauvre monsieur charest
parce que on sait que pierre poilievre
jouit des jeux des deux d'appuis assez
nombreux au sein du caucus donc monsieur
charest veut montrer qu'il ne partira
pas de si loin en arrière chivu rat voir
une représentativité géographique
minimale s'ils se présentent avec
seulement des députés québécois derrière
lui puis quelques-uns des provinces
maritimes ou atlantique en de l'ontario
mais ça ne suffira pas à le dépeindre un
grand rassembleur dont c'est un défi de
monsieur charest et ça c'est quand même
étonnant qu'il n'ait pas une plus grande
audience ne serait ce que par curiosité
je sais pas à quel point il ya beaucoup
de choses à faire mercredi soir à ottawa
- max alors pointe encore des buts fait
envie
mais parce qu'il y ait des grandes
questions qui se posent sur ses
positions
fait intéressant de voir qu'il ya
plusieurs personnes qui réclamaient qui
réclament le retour de jean charest mais
on n'est pas vraiment capable de dire
quelle position il va défendre à bord
que on présume qu est ce qu ont hanté
par entre celle de pierre boilley et du
gouvernement trudeau mais bon c'est pas
la version bêta leeds oui on a hâte de
voir aussi le jour où il va se présenter
s'il le fait comment ils voient le
justifier lui qui disait il ya deux ans
que le parti conservateur avait trop
changer puis
s comment il va se comporter le jeu
présenté en sauveur en fait il ya
beaucoup de questions mais on n'est pas
encore rendu là manifestement on attend
toujours cette annonce qu'elle se
déclare bonne journée powers hélène
buzzetti merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir au revoir merci
[Musique]